previously on grave robbers the show
where we put permadeath in every single
game if you die in a game you move on to
the next I'm here with Mary you're not
Mike I'm not Mike oh that's a chainsaw
chainsaw I know I want to quit the show
I aggro'd ten people yeah I'm in deep
[ __ ] I can survive getting hit I can't
survive the chainsaw I'm thick I'm
actually I'm in deep
[Music]
[Applause]
this seems like a lot nicer of an
experience
[Laughter]
oh I knew that was gonna I knew that was
gonna happen
you're alive cool all tight Weiss I'm
I've died in the show too falling damage
no way oh my god no don't you're egging
me on I can't let it be a third time I'm
not doing it
you just want to play hollow Knight
that's not that's not how this works
I need support what's yo well you know
not everything goes according to plan no
sometimes you chain side of the dome
[Music]
welcome to grave hoppers my name is Rob
this is Mary this is the show where we
put permadeath in every game if you die
in the game you move on to another one
and as you saw there you yeah you died I
died I died by a chainsaw guy I I spent
a lot of the last week thinking about
this and it's generally the case when
you die in the show you think about all
weekend I really am disappointed with
the performance I think I just I think I
underestimated that area and how tight
that space is you have to like basically
kill everyone before you go forward and
I was trying to dash through it and they
absolutely paid for it it was a bummer
I'll take some blame because I said run
I should not have said that but you he
was so close it was like just get past
them I think it was a really good
learning experience I had a really good
time overall and now you get to play
breath of the wild I do so here's where
at and I have also some bad news I so I
really do so last week I mean you broke
the record regardless we didn't hit no
you didn't hit the hour oh yeah we we
were hoping you would but you were that
short like I was generous engaging so I
for the most part like what I'm doing is
I'm gauging when like the game actually
there's an opportunity where you could
die right like there's no tutorials all
that stuff for instance lots of us
there's a whole heavy tutorial so that
was like legit 1 minute 25 seconds but
you just shy great and now we're in a
while it was disappointing Eric green
asked what was my Chris response to my
message let me find it because I did I
did send him he said god dammit and I
said it was the chainsaw and then he
didn't respond well you know he was
disappointed it's fine it's the neat you
know it just happens this is the name of
the game it's the show well let's get
into it
crime tomb 17 minutes still kills me not
a lot of time that's not but here we are
ok so we have a strategy yes so I think
where I'm at right now like you know
we're trying to play this game and I
have been thinking about as well so far
it's I would I want to say it's like
it's appearing to be easy but I will die
somehow really so we're actually playing
ok I got a look alive
so yeah I pay attention here's what I'm
thinking go on obviously Gannon is gonna
be the end game right now I want to get
Impa Impa
I think I'm gonna go to Cocorico or I
like to call it karaoke village and talk
with her and then I think my plan is to
do some shrines get some say I'm gonna
get some hearts and then take on Ganon I
think that sounds like a good strat
imeem the last thing all set
forgot how fun this game I think that
you don't want to just spend your time
getting karak seeds here let's get it
done somebody's how many hours are you
spending this game over 600 well it
should I really I really like this game
Mary I know you do
I think it's it's a very fun and
relaxing game to play it's very zen it's
calming and I think you need those yeah
like that's how I was playing it too
like I was just like I put on a show
something and just send the couch in
just kind of mess around me and holo
night man yeah I like actually look for
excuses to play it again because it's so
calming for me that game is darker it's
a bit it's kind of like death focus but
yeah I find it calming anyway yeah and
it's my game to relax it used to be
spelunky oh sure you know Chris waters
used to tell me Chris waters used to
work here he's amazing he's a beautiful
man and he told me he used to play one
round a spelunky before he went to sleep
it was a really nice way to like fall
asleep also like here's another thing I
just had a panic attack a mod one like
it well so you lose stamina but if I hit
the water and I have like I forget that
like oh I hit the round I do drown
instantly so it's like should you not
have come here
no I was just playing it like like I
don't how much stamina so I'm trying to
say so like hang glider and my actions
so I could've just easily screwed myself
over just here if I like we're to fall
off with no stamina cuz I would have
died hey I understand we're saying yeah
you have to plan you took that balloon
so as long as you can climb this but you
have enough stamina to be careful with
your jumps man because you get there
faster but you can burn through your
stamina yeah I've made that mistake
before for sure that's the thing
especially over water
that's a good question Eric green I
think no drowning is game over I'm
pretty sure it has to have a game over
screen right different Fred enshrines ja
yeah like falling in a shrine where you
lose half a heart and you just appear if
it gives you a game over screen yeah
that's death but it's interesting to
have those conversations of like are you
getting a cross I mean he was just right
here the designer gave him a full face
mask and nothing down there I think
they're like dogs they like don't need
it yeah pretty much
like dogs that is rude justifying naked
creature
[Laughter]
okay so uh okay so is your plan to just
well cuz it gets really cold like I was
thinking I could like this game is so
interesting like you kind of have to
abide by like certain paths and
beginning because I just don't want have
to deal with being frozen up there great
that's coming forcing me to like go
through this Canyon which all this do a
lot of people are saying that when you
drown you do not get a game over screen
Oh hearts which is good so you know [ __ ]
around you know what I'm thinking of is
in freezing water like I just had a
vision like in water where it's really
cold you guys you don't drown well
technically you do drown but like you'd
actually die from being frozen I'm just
I'm having that visual maybe they're
right
Ken's asking where my dog is my dog is
not here
gamespot only has one day a month where
they allow dogs I fought it with every
fiber of my being but I couldn't win you
did you know your dog likes to fight
I've had him in this room and done
streams with him and it's rough because
he's always farting I saw you almost
think about that bird mm-hmm considered
arrows it's so enjoyable to go down a
mountain I know it really is I'm also
probably damaging that's a party I'm not
doing that
Oh what is that
oh it's those guys oh my god it's a hole
oh it's a whole
what do you call core huh octo rocks a
whole group quick someone check Oh God
all right I'm just gonna know oh there's
monsters over there it's a party
okay I think they're leaving you alone
wing zero I have a French Bulldog he's
adorable
name is C Mon it's rough I get it I get
you it's slow come on what oh I didn't
see him use your binocs oh this is a
hole what is that oh it's a skull yeah
what they did all right just be sneaky
it's not sneaky
what Oh God there are a lot of them
protecting that tower there's some meat
there do you want that meat kind of hmm
I would eat just in case just to fill I
don't want to get salmonella here just
half a heart I don't really have much
just eat the best just as a safety
because once I remember you got hit and
you had half a heart left okay they
didn't notice they didn't notice they're
too little cooking spot there's three of
them oh there's three of them I don't
want to I don't I don't like i don't
want three of these guys I respect your
choice he'll live your life your only
life no see I think that's kind of like
a thing that comes with streaming
without dying perma death is that you
kind of have to lean or mode the whole
game where you get chainsawed to the
face where he can't nice chainsaw to the
dome snipe oh my
[Music]
grabbing them and shoving them in his
pocket as he's swimming yeah Oh bat have
you had a Blood Moon yet no that's like
something I worry about yeah the worst
is like so many times I've like pushed
through like an encampment like going on
a path and there's a ton of enemies and
then Blood Moon happens and then you're
just surrounded it's like the worst what
oh yeah
careful with your jumping I think you're
getting a little eager well too eager
I'll show you Mary push it to the limit
oh ho that's my favorite the sound he
makes me as a horse oh ho
I love his noises yeah I would love to
be a fly on the wall when they were
doing that that's good take it again oh
[Laughter]
no no really feel like you're climbing
take it again they put him on a rock
wall I did just tell him thank you
literally just told you I know behind
every death of a man there's a woman who
literally just told him don't do that
it's literally the last thing he hears
you're gonna die why get more stamina
when it's a one death challenge it's
actually an interesting question because
we did have the option of getting more
hearts or more stamina we went with
stamina because there was an incident
not very long ago in the last episode
where he almost died because he was
being chased and he couldn't outrun him
stamina it's it's debatable I would
argue that having stamina gives you a
better chance at survival because you
can outrun and you can just do
everything faster whereas hearts yeah
you can take more damage but if you
can't avoid the damage you're just gonna
keep taking damage and die and we're
avoiding large fights so it's a it's a
worthy discussion but I think there's
value in saying stamina will help him be
a wiener and like run from everything
and that's the that's the tactic we're
using here and climbing in general too
you have to climb in this game we're not
doing are we doing fast travel yeah so
the the thing I wanted come on
maybe my flat fast-travel is that if you
know the game you you can really
basically warp out of any situation I'm
not gonna do that if I'm in combat I'm
not gonna warp out yeah
or use warp as like a way of cheating
death
totally but if I need to get from A to B
quicker I'm gonna work I think that's
fair so also in one of the villages some
armor oh I didn't realize that was on
there that's like one one of the things
I mean there's there are many you know
issues with this game just like any game
but one of the things that just always
got to me he's like why'd I have to make
that sensor noise so annoying or like at
least turn it off so you could just see
like the flash I don't know great like
sometimes they just own stuff like like
not Zelda louder no sir I think it's too
louder make it higher pitched yeah yeah
it's a weird choice you ever see um they
changed the way when you pay now with
your credit card and it makes like a
beeping horrible noise when you've
successfully paid for something yeah but
it sounds like a negative yeah I
understand it yeah baby
B B good job you bought it it's like
shouldn't it be like nice sounding yeah
just something good right it's
unnecessary
does Master mode change anything like in
ocarina of time or is it just harder
says wings ear so it changes a whole lot
Oh God
it changes a whole bunch so if you saw
like those platforms that are flying the
that's only in master mode so they add
they add like higher tiered enemies they
add the enemies can see you from they
can see you when you call it further
away sight is better but most of those
things you could argue are just harder
so what else
oh other just content general yeah I'm
sorry you could argue that those are
just things that make the game harder
right like it takes longer to hit them
nice yeah and there's also like risky
there's like a there's like a gold clasp
actually that was probably in I can't
remember that was in normal mode or that
might get there
I think a hut hut should do it
you don't make ice snow that's water can
you jump from this upper area and make
it
I think I can make that I'm sorry I
don't have some crack though there's
like there anything else outside of life
enemies being harder that's changed
because of the moon I want to say
there's something else but for the most
part it's just like more enemies on
those platforms that's probably really
good that makes sense
just listen that was a fluke if I play
again I'm not gonna die in five minutes
just dog not fair
second of all the purpose of the show is
to beat it somehow I think taking on
Ganon without dying once tricky because
you're not going to get that strong with
the way you're playing all right
random oh this is where it's given me
all the DLC stuff oh so okay that is
technically in master mode I mean you'd
get that regardless all the stuff but
like in order to play master mode you
have to buy the DLC and this Wow
it's arguable like the mode the mode
could have been free but you just um
[Music]
skirt by are you gonna kill them there's
a explosion barrel there hey
oh there's not that dead
no I mean oh they recharge health - oh
okay there's I don't think bombs are
doing a lot of damage
no but they push him back that is nice I
just want to focus on one these guys so
we got get Joey gotcha ah sorry see it's
like one hit it's one slip sorry for
yelling
that happened so fast no maybe this will
help God everything's on fire you need
to kill him here on fire
yeah he is - oh good he's dead
good job does he have a weapon here
shield
torch yes it might be a value for you to
play with the shield to defend yourself
because you're so so weak that's the
thing but like I don't I would need a
one-handed weapon just this but right
it's just a very different style of play
it's just it's it's a weaker weapon is
the thing uh-huh let's cook actually I
love the [ __ ] song
yeah the cooking song is like when you
cook something that's not food
and they're like I don't know what that
is Bank dubious food all right this
should give me an armor who's you could
use that for one minute sick I mean you
could use it I call they they were
sleeping and they just immediately get
up and dance were you guys sleeping too
sick
here he comes he knows nice oh I saw
that yeah almost got you yeah the spears
have rained with the pointy end
oh he very adamant see you very agile
this guy move it is you're okay you're
not great but you're okay your clubs not
doing great
throw it oh did you not hit him nobody
heard it
cool
you only have one now you can take him
out with a stick throwing a twig at them
oh yeah it's slow well I'm doing a
wind-up move seems like it paid off
kill him nope you didn't but you will
know all right he did yeah I'm seeing a
couple people saying extra hearts bonus
hearts would be good for these types of
things yeah so there are some items I
could I could like a hearty durian the
durians are another one which I like new
who live where they were I know some
areas but like they're really far away
yeah we can evil be back next week Mike
is in Paris right now and as soon as he
comes back we'll record another episode
he's been gone for two weeks traveling
out drunk doing his thing when he gets
back we'll start again I think we start
with our 100th episode which is crazy
he's almost in the water no he's got a
stick literally almost Preston yeah oh
nice
thanks for the spirits to bed it's one
of my favorite parts about this game is
that you can steal their weapons and
then he gets all pissed off my boss is
gonna be so mad at me
area he's dead well it wasn't an easy
fight but you're taking care of it into
the water with you they don't even have
like a drowning process they just
immediately drown no they squirm and
stuff he was dead thanks thirty cow we
love doing it I've missed doing it and
I'm behind now or like I've been playing
a game and I took two weeks off and now
I forget where I was yeah how to play so
this is probably the other thing with
this game I always hate is like yoi can
they have the option of like okay fine
my inventory's full let me switch out
like now like to the amount of time I've
spent going back and forth in between
the music's 9% it's so ridiculous like
that's one thing they like could totally
fix don't they just double down on it
for those of you who are not keen on the
show it's called grape hoppers where we
have looking this is our list right now
so we're on breath of the wild if you
die in a game you move on to the next so
you get one life these are all the times
on the right there mary did the best so
far with 59 minutes yeah killed it
literally and we're on Zelda here hey
Errol yay yeah happy birthday to Callie
I do the shrine I like want hearts right
I mean you gotta you gotta go through
the emotions no we're not doing any
fishing Eric there's also no fishing in
this game let me actually there kind of
is I guess you just pick them up you
don't get a fish Pole you fish while
you're swimming you just chuck them in
your shirt doesn't fish squirming
everyone's like man Zelda or his like
link woke up but like he smells
I'm just covering himself in the fish
they're like in his pants and stuff guys
like weird
oh yeah do we make it one fishel our
great you've done it you've broken the
record oh yeah good job
one hour of many hours there
it's a weapon I want it sometimes it's
like a torch it's never a torch but yeah
[Laughter]
don't be a torch please
also I've full inventory so okay really
you were broke ass so that's nice you
got wait was your first 50 rupees you
want no rupees damn well have you been
doing a bomb he's all I could've at
least given me like 50 bucks to spawn
right get out there and be somebody you
loser
I don't know sell your clothes or
something [ __ ] here's a toy for my mom I
just could I just revive you so needy
oh come on you big dumb idiot
you need a third one I don't know we'll
find out come on nice in the ball hurt
you yeah trust me I thought about it
[Music]
let's get some sleep skip skip skip skip
skip skip
did you ever see you probably done the
DLC was really cool there's there's
something really cool that happens when
that with one of these guys okay great I
think I've missed a lot of the secrets I
did play through Zelda and beat it but
then I realized there was a lot of stuff
I didn't do like I didn't get all the
story cutscenes apparently those were
really important to find them all yeah
and I think I didn't find like two of
them for no reason no good reason I just
played the game and I beat the game and
then I was like I guess I'll play
another game and that's the story you
really had to dig for the story like
that being said it's you know it's
definitely not great once you like to
see it all the only cool thing about the
memories is that some of them are
they're interesting in that you don't
learn like when you watch them all like
they there are hidden kind of meetings
in each one that you might not know I
guess open the stable hopefully it's
only $50 hey I do
damnit Oh big dumb dumb dumb can't you
see I'm working a switch shirt I got
this have you heard about our Lord and
Savior switch here's a pamphlet I need a
horse alright I should I actually
probably a horse let's do that
you get the true ending if you find all
the memories I think then maybe this is
like a detriment it like I was working
at GameSpot at the time but sometimes
when you're you're under a lot of
pressure to kind of like constantly move
on so it can be tough to like when I
played the game and I beat the game I
was like I beat the game now I don't
play the next game for sure and so I I
probably didn't spend as much time in
this game as I wanted whereas like now
I've like I'm on my third run of Hollow
and I and it's like I just I think I'll
just hang out in this one area for four
hours because I can yeah I was like
Robert horses can't do they hurt you
they kick you I think they just run away
they can totally kick you in real life
they can kick you question answered such
a perfect kick do come on come here
where you going now yeah yeah yeah you
didn't think that through
oh yeah oh yeah I have no stamina don't
oh that's okay hey kill that person and
then take its course
great Choo choos oh yeah I got him
though I think I got him well I'm do you
maybe I didn't I do don't give a [ __ ]
about you you got a dude oh great to
choose just what I need the lamest
things I think I've ever said oh oh you
did get him oh great
jojo's hawk rain My Luck you chose piano
it's just a lovely tune oh I don't know
why but I was like stressed about it oh
I didn't mean to do that
how much mrs. live I wonder how much
this is because I only have 50 bucks
try to handle fish hey it'll be $400 yep
yeah okay yeah got it keep the change ya
filthy animal name it quick top your
head but stallions another one all right
fine they were like everyone go to like
the but auditorium and he's like dammit
I wish we didn't let the children name I
think it didn't like it I think there
are some no no names
well you gotta hide it yes true
Epona that's just like so obvious
come on there nobody ever expects but
stuff alright moving on
on second thought nah I'm good
God it seems but stall could not hear
your call you know but stall and we
allowed twitch to name a plant on a show
recently called artificial and they
chose the name tiana weaves
[Music]
[Music]
he's such a character Wow
you roll masses
I named my horse poop but that's pretty
good too because it's also good I would
bet on but stall for Kentucky Derby
great I'm broke but star for the win
what are you buying
oh just for one I I got my math wrong
you have like $10 f30 really should be
fine mm-hmm
take them out but you're done I think I
can yeah link doesn't talk so you can
kind of improvise or pretend how he
would be like maybe he does say smell
you later to everyone yeah he's kind of
a brat I was a brat she's like come he's
gotta be full himself he's the chosen
one
what up loser what's your thing oh he
had bomb arrows Oh to that town that
time I remember cuz is where you meet
the guy who's like get korek seeds and
I'll trade them first stuff does he have
maracas no you just shake shake it baby
yeah I can see you they gave him a side
bag but no pants so weird-looking dude
oh yeah I gotta fight these guys let's
do it let's fight him a cartoon back in
the day where's no no link was like a
total [ __ ] to Zelda and would like
any time she was a Kishin talk to me
like that he's like well excuse me
princess it's just like a piece of [ __ ]
it was like a weird take on link that's
pretty funny I haven't seen that that's
also Star Wars console oh for sure I
base as I watch your toys
all right here okay
shoot I don't have one shoot them in the
butt and set a trap with bombs oh they
found you run like hell like I just did
a wall jump your evasion is good but you
almost killed your horse can you knock
them off the cliff
yeah at least they pause every time okay
it's going well guys doing a super
attack so he'll be tired come on I want
to do like hey where you guys going you
know I [ __ ] this guy let's go back to
our cave won't hear your story Oh
perfect idiot oh my god
shanked that guy remember to use stasis
on them so that's the thing is I don't
have that ability yet at the upgrade I
have to upgrade stasis in order to do it
you haven't earned that right hundred
and trust me I will be using this
this is good all right what's your plan
here but bombing
oh yeah knock him off there's one that's
like your fortnight dance he's got
something up his butt he's stalled he's
stalled what Oh are they not dead he's
right there move you're he's so confused
as soon as I find out where I am I'm
gonna kill that guy what the hell was
that
yep Oh what the hell was that oh you're
not gonna oh what the hell he and he
healed up oh yeah all right you're going
to go down there
should i I know I do because I think the
quest requires him to die I can't climb
this
why didn't you die when I told you to
die supposed to die like that
okay okay
I should have bombed him it was a closed
space could have accidentally bombed
yourself Mira great I'll save that for
later climb the ship I would not be
jumping you know me this is gonna take
an hour I don't think I can make that I
mean there's only one way to find out is
there any place that you can stand
because if you can just stand there and
reclaim your stamina it's worth it okay
let's do this pump it up
oh my god I'm a jumper okay I'm a jumper
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
things like you you get that one jump
and it's like a fat lunge I'm coming
what stall this way chicka-boom
chicka-boom but he still got it that new
show on HBO I heard I heard he's a
painter
yeah it's to paint now dude everyone
do you really can Shakalaka shucks I so
original I think we'll go with a weapons
side oh yeah
it's just a popper you got it hey link
hates this experience yeah every time
Rock a weirdo with his murse he's like
I'm a one-man Wolf Pack
did you so you know you there are 900 of
these stupid seeds all over the world do
you know what happens when you get them
all together no I think it's pretty it's
pretty messed up you think it you think
it would be a huge reward but it's like
a piece of crap literally [ __ ] yeah it's
like it's technically you could say it's
a trophy I haven't done it I forgot what
it looks like but it's pretty much a
piece of crap like it's like ridiculous
I remember seeing something on Twitter
about like here's what happens when you
get all the croc seeds and then senior
Commons just being like oh that's not
great yeah like Justin hey Walt did it I
can't
what's together he's stuck on a rock
what's that girl some in your butt hate
you but he dumb majestic he doesn't know
how to run the dumbest horse in Hyrule
are you let's get moving but stop come
on butch doll thank you big dumb idiot
jump goofball you pretty buddy dumb as
hell this town is so cool always losers
losers no that's that's actually what
link sounds like it's the sheikah slate
it's called a sheep hi my name is lake
you idiot no I'm trying to get them but
stall I know where it is I'm the chosen
one
shut up wait what if you are evil and
you're like the prequels you're killing
yourself you become smarter destroy you
always you never have the high ground
frame myself dibs oh yeah
oh here's a question what armor did I go
for I would say or stealth stealth or
climbing so this isn't climbing that's
just like health damn that's 280 will
you have zero rupees well zero rubies
get me nothing okay stick them up I
think I can you could sell all this crap
I don't need this link Skywalker hell
yeah
well at least there's one piece of gear
that'll buy you a shirt
stop saying that she's making me
uncomfortable
[Music]
alright I think I could get a fit I
think you could I could do a little mix
and match show you that like I can do
half stealth half Hylian yeah do you get
something if you're wearing all three
pieces yeah you right what's up yes and
could see more health armor I don't know
I should do stealth like I don't think
cuz this set doesn't have any benefit
other than looking awesome it does look
good but I think stealth is gonna help
you stay alive in this tough environment
I think you're right
it's a cool fit oh yeah it's like
tighter 500 oh you fudged up so seven
lady
alright health Haiti alright I don't
want to wear this shirt anymore so let's
get this and just bite bite the bullet
stop your store socks on my way I'm the
chosen one
I'm the way idiot
oh don't shame her Mary listen she just
talks the way she talks
nice oh I like how its got like a
turtleneck you look good
I do look good
I think has no redeemable qualities he's
just a guy who runs about the woods
putting fireworks I'm sleeping God put
on a shirt it has been quite a long time
there's a badass
they've done some good design of all
their characters like the sand dunes
areas the leak the lead character in
that the girl is like so cool looking
it's such a good job what's her name
your Bosa is that it just extremely cool
outfit and face and everything I said no
yeah this is master mode Dylan and you
can tell by the bottom left corner there
there's a Triforce that's how you know
oh no thanks it has been an hour a
hundred years ago skip skip skip skip I
understand yeah I know about those
so now you go through the long process
[Music]
okay should we call it sure unless you
got something else you can do quick um
what else could I do quickly I don't
know I can get another get another fight
just for hell of it
I feel like fighting is something I
don't typically hear you say what game
are we playing next holo night it'll be
Halle night
unfortunately I've like forced Mike to
play hollow night now but I think he
likes that game works out yeah that
would be a good one oh that's good I'll
go for that shrimp less trying to stop
there can you make this yeah no problem
Oh a raft oh oh yeah yeah how are you
gonna get there I smell a car come here
you stupid stupid my berries look at me
I have a thing on my face hey well let
me see my kids there is a what is that
that's what oh oh oh
[Music]
okay it's a lizard so these guys really
suck they're like probably the most
annoying
look at them they're so annoying yeah
well what do you okay his day off
all right wait there's two if you get
alert the other one moaning maybe oh he
turned around hey [ __ ] work out over
here yeah oh he's fast
you don't know good job good job okay
yes yes oh God
nice jeez you did it that was great that
was a nice clean kill you know what what
it is low you could not survive one hit
I actually would have definitely always
I love how he becomes green oh oh don't
turn around don't turn around don't turn
around don't turn around don't around
gotcha the trickiness
what's there nice it's a good tactic
vengeful
I was good though cuz those guys are
fast and scary they really are good job
cool let's call it there okay that
should save your progress yeah it's
going well yeah it is it's going well
this is the longest this is the longest
runs anyone's survived I think you've
gotten some good progress you have more
stamina now you have to just beat the
four so you don't have to I don't think
I will
oh you're not so you're just gonna build
your hearts and stamina and then go for
Ganon yeah I feel like that's just like
needless like you get cool abilities but
like like you can and heat like they'll
they'll knock off half of Ganon's health
if you get all four also nice yeah it
sounds like a nice thing to do but but
that's it so you don't have to know I
don't have to this is we're on breath oh
wow this is this is still going on
hollow nights next an alien isolation
I'm really excited about I have it
booted up my booted up just in case and
I played about like five seconds so I
was like oh my god disgust it's just so
surreal and immersive like first-person
like it's terrifying you can hear
everything yeah
alright well that's gonna do it thank
you so much for stepping in thanks for
having me so next week Mike will be back
back you are gonna go back to Zelda back
to Zelda and yeah in any event of myself
or Mike being out you should you should
you know yeah you guys are it's always
fun to come back and hang out with you
guys so thanks for having me in before
I'll be I'll be around I'm like two
blocks away you are so easy it's so easy
alright well thank you guys so much for
watching stay tuned next week every
Thursday 2:00 p.m. and you can catch us
live streaming every day of the week
11:00 a.m. Pacific GameSpot GameSpot see
you guys nice outro
[Music]
you